اخبار العالم ايجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم قتل احوا عشرات الجرح انفجار في
شارع الاستقلال في منطقه تقسيم وسط
اسطنبول
نتنياهو يتسلموا من الرئيس الاسرائيلي
خطاب التكليف الرسمي لتشكيل الحكومه
الجديده وفي كلمه الله عقب التكليف تعهد
نتنياهو بحكومه مسؤوله ومستقره واكدا على
وجوب العمل بحزم ضدنا وصفها لعدوانيه
ايرانه وهذه الحكومه هي السادسه لانتنياهو
وتوصف بالاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ الاحتلال
في قمه ثلاثيه الولايات المتحده تقول انها
اكثر اتفاقا مع كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
كوريا
بمنطقه الهندي
معه فوضى العلامه الزرقاء على تويتر ايلي
ليلي اكبر شركه مصنعه للانسولين البشريه
تعتذر عن معلومات كاذبه نشرت على حساب
مزيف يحمل علامه التوفيق الزرقاء من تويتر
والذي اعلن ان الانسولين اصبح متاحا
بالمجان الاعلان المزيف تسبب في تكبر
الشركه خسائر بلغت 15 مليار دولار في ساعه